Republicans held more hearings yesterday
these are hearings where Republicans are
determined to show that the FBI has been
weaponized by the left against the right
the first problem that Republicans had
yesterday in making that case is that
they had testimony
from Christopher Ray Christopher Ray is
the director of the FBI Christopher Ray
is a republican Christopher Ray votes
for republicans and Christopher Wray was
the selection of Republican president
Donald Trump to lead the FBI and yet
this did not stop Republicans from
making fools of themselves with all
sorts of allegations you're defending
Hunter Biden you're covering for the
bidens you're targeting Republicans none
of which are based in any actual
evidence we're going to look at these
clips and the point that I really want
to hit home here for you
is that this is our money being spent
we talk about you know I pay taxes I
don't like my money being used for so
many weapons I don't like my money being
used for Wars fine I agree
I also don't like my money used for
political theater
that goes nowhere uncovers nothing
and it is this sort of thing now our our
friend congressman Ted Liu a Democrat he
had a brilliant line of questioning
we're going to get to the Republican
questioning in a moment which was which
was cuckoo Ted Lou had a brilliant line
of questioning here that speaks for
itself let's take a listen Trump advisor
Roger Stone was convicted in a federal
court correct
that's my recollection
Trump donor Elliot Brady was convicted
in a federal court correct
also my recollection
the Attorney General at the time for
those two convictions was Bill Barr
which president nominated Bill Barr for
attorney general uh president Trump
Trump's former lawyer Michael Cohen was
convicted on two separate occasions in a
federal court correct
I believe that's correct the Attorney
General at the time for Cohen's second
conviction was Matthew Whitaker
which president appointed Matthew
Whitaker as acting Attorney General
uh president Trump
's foreign campaign chairman Paul
manafort was convicted in a federal
court correct
yes Trump's former deputy campaign
manager Mr Gates was convicted in a
federal court correct that's my
recollection from this campaign foreign
policy adviser George Papadopoulos was
convicted in a federal court correct
Drew uh yes I think he pled guilty yes
the Attorney General at the time of
those three cases was Jeff sessions
which president nominated Jeff sessions
for attorney general president Trump
you were their FBI director for all of
those cases at the time which president
nominated you president Trump okay
what'd these facts show is we don't have
a two-tiered system of justice we have
one Department of Justice that goes
after criminals regardless of party
ideology
all of these folks were convicted under
the administrations of three separate
Republican Attorneys General
it is not the fault of the FBI that
Donald Trump surrounded himself with
criminals this is of course such an
obvious point that I can't believe needs
to be made but the vast majority of
those who were convicted under this
supposedly weaponized FBI were convicted
under the leadership of a republican FBI
director and Republican Attorneys
General now this was like the the best
moment of this entire hearing we then
get to some of the cartoonish moments
here is Republican Congressman chip Roy
trying to make the case that the FBI has
behaved in a tyrannical way an FBI
director Ray struggling to get a word in
edgewise but managing to explain why
that's not the case your job is to
protect the American people from a
tyrannical FBI storming the home of an
American family I could not disagree
more with your description of the FBI as
tyrannical and I don't believe
I wish they would let Witnesses answer
questions Tom the gentleman's expired
witness May respond and then we'll move
to our next witness are they
respectfully
they did not storm his house
they came to his door
they knocked on his door and identified
themselves they asked him to exit he did
without incident
whenever our agents well not at gunpoint
whenever our agents conduct an arrest
their arms our agents are armed
virtually all the time as you may
remember from your own experience as a
prosecutor what's so funny about these
arguments that they make these are the
arguments that when on the left concern
is expressed generally about you know
sometimes when some of these warrants
are served
do we really need so much Firepower and
Republicans go absolutely it's dangerous
out there for members of law enforcement
they must be armed at all time this is
just the way it is
now all of a sudden
armed agents by which we mean like they
carry handguns as all of these
individuals do showed up and knocked on
the door oh my goodness that's
oppressive use of force it's militarized
where were you guys were for a decade
we've been talking about the
militarization of police forces for
example pathetic Hypocrites then we go
to Harriet Hageman she accused
Christopher Wray of discriminating
against Republicans and he explains I'm
a Republican and just none of this makes
any sense
um Mr Ray from the Twitter files
Missouri versus Biden disclosures the
Durham investigation and report and
exposure and collapse to the Russian
collusion hoax the American people fully
understand that there is a two-tier
justice system that has been weaponized
to persecute People based on their
political beliefs of course most people
don't believe that and there's no
evidence of that and that you have
personally been weapon that you have
personally worked to weaponize the FBI
conservatives
I asked Mr Durham about this to which he
answered I don't think that things can
go too much further with the view that
law enforcement particularly the FBI or
Department of Justice runs a two-tiered
system of justice the nation can't stand
under those circumstances director Ray
what are you prepared to do to reform
federal law enforcement in a manner
which earns back the trust of the
American people well first off I would
disagree with your characterization of
the FBI and certainly your description
of my own approach the idea that I'm
biased against conservatives
seems somewhat insane to me given my own
personal background as to how we are
approaching our work of protecting the
American people and upholding the
Constitution it starts with me having
emphasized to all of our folks over and
over and over again in everything we do
that we need to do the right thing in
the right way and that means following
the facts wherever they lead no matter
who likes it this is your money being
wasted the money that is being wasted on
this hearing could go to almost anything
and it would be a better investment than
this then we go to Matt Gates
congressman from Florida Matt Gates
tries to make the case that the FBI is
just simply not trusted right now and
Christopher Ray says so many people even
from your state congressman gates are
desperate to work for us people trusted
the FBI more when Jay Edgar Hoover was
running the place than when you are and
the reason is because you don't give
straight answers you give answers that
later a court deems aren't true and then
at the end of the day you won't
criticize an obvious Shakedown when it's
directly in front of us and it appears
as though you're whitewashing the
conduct of corrupt people respectfully
Congressman in your home state of
Florida the number of people applying to
come work for us and devote their lives
working for us is over up over a hundred
percent we're deeply proud
uh and then Gates tries to uh pin
protecting the bidens on Christopher Ray
uh of which there is of course no
evidence I will make certain that
they've been sitting next to me and
every person he knows and my ability to
forever hold a grudge that you will
regret not following my direction I am
sitting here waiting for the call with
my father
sounds like a Shakedown doesn't IT
director
I'm not going to get into commenting on
that you you seem deeply uncurious about
it don't you almost suspicious
especially I'm curious are you
protecting the bidens
absolutely not the FBI was not has no
interest you won't answer the question
about whether or not that's a Shakedown
and everybody knows why you won't answer
it because to EV to the millions of
people who will see this they know it is
and your inability to acknowledge that
is deeply revealing about you but let's
go now the truth is it would be
completely inappropriate for Christopher
Wray in a setting like this to just
weigh in on the meaning of alleged
quotes about it it's completely outside
of the scope of what the FBI director
can and should be doing but what we have
to remember is that to me and to most of
you we see this and we go this is
nothing this is like when you pour water
on cotton candy and it just evaporates
into nothing it's not literal
evaporation okay uh it crumbles into
nothing but the Maga people will see
this and they'll go Rey is suspicious it
is suspicious that he won't weigh in on
these things just out of the blue that
Matt Gates brings up a waste of my
taxpayer money a waste of your taxpayer
money but to some degree it is
accomplishing its goal which is to
weaponize the hearings against federal
law enforcement
I've had such trouble finding a great
razor where I am not cutting myself for
getting those Nicks on my skin which are
so common with the cheap disposable
razors you have to meet our sponsor
Henson shaving Henson actually
manufactures parts for the International
Space Station and the Mars rover and
they are bringing that exact same
Precision Engineering to the Shaving
experience it hurts when you shave
because blades extend too far and thus
they wobble slightly but with their
Aerospace grade CNC machines Henson is
able to make metal razors that extend
just
0.0013 inches that's less than the
thickness of a human hair which means a
secure stable Blade with the vibration
free shave it also has built-in channels
to evacuate the hair and the cream no
more clogs no more rubbing your thumb on
the razor to get the hair out I use
Henson at home shaving is a great
experience now Henson wants to be the
best razor not the best razor business
which means you only need to buy it once
and it's awesome go to hensonshaving.com
Pacman add a razor and a hundred pack of
blades to your cart then enter the code
Pacman to get the hundred blades for
free that is a three year Supply the
link is down below